this is actually the third in a series
of three talks that we've had in the
series of seminars about long-term
thinking one was by Roger Kennedy used
to be head of the National Park Service
talking about basically the last ten
thousand years of American history and
one of the things he pointed out helped
lead up to this talk which is that a
number of times there have been very
advanced civilizations north of the
Aztecs up here in North America that
Chaco at Cahokia and other places that
were pretty darn advanced and crashed
and in some places like in Ohio
once they crash that place stayed
basically forbidden for centuries
afterwards and we also had a talk from
Daniel Janssen referring to how to
protect wilderness you really have to
understand it it has got to be a paying
proposition that you can't just preserve
someplace and say it's going to be okay
now it's got to pay its way we've had
some talks on the urbanization of the
world that's going on now and some side
effects of that which may be that people
living in dense circumstances have less
environmental impact and folks who are
scattered all across the landscape
either driving around or burning
firewood
so there's a sequence of ideas gradually
emerging in the course of this series of
lectures that is feeding into a body of
thought about long term thinking that's
the whole point of this Jared Diamond
coming from his work on Guns Germs and
Steel and now on the book collapse is
someone who has brought his scientific
skills and historical skills that he's
added to them and has done some of the
most serious rigorous retrospective look
at how civilization behaves
in aggregate and overtime and it's your
to do it tonight
[Applause]
let me first check whether you'll be
able to hear me okay and dak can you
hear okay doc it's a great pleasure for
me all used to be back in San Francisco
which I can sit which for me is the most
beautiful American city one of the most
beautiful cities in the world I don't
know how many of you here know from
Franz Schubert's last song cycle that he
completed shortly before others death
fine and Kazan
there's a wonderful sore mysterious song
they're called dich doch in which
Schubert with the music describes the
towers of a city rising through the mist
and I think of that song every time I
crossed the bay bridge and see San
Francisco emerging in the distance and
it's also a city with fond memories for
me because my parents spent 20 the last
30 years of their lives here and I think
the happiest years in San Francisco so
I'm very happy to be back here people
often ask me why is it that I chose to
write a book on the subject of collapses
of societies and the answer is simple it
was the most fascinating and important
and central subject that I could think
of to write about after finishing Guns
Germs and Steel it appears that the
public also finds this subject of
collapse fascinating too because as soon
as the book was released in January
within three days it was on top of the
bestseller less now an author likes to
believe that of a book sells well is
because of that authors beautiful
writing a great book but since my book
sold well even before it but he could
have read it it was clear that had
nothing to do with my beautiful writing
but simply that people recognized the
raw nerve that the subject of collapse
touches and they want to understand
the book originated as an account of
romantic mysteries past societies that
collapsed leaving behind as abandoned
monuments the remains of cities now
covered up by jungle or cities in the
desert as a teenager I like most view
here was fascinated by the abandoned
statues of Easter Island the Maya cities
the ruined cities of the Fertile
Crescent and we all asked ourselves why
on earth did people build cities in an
area where nobody is trying to make an
urban living today and why having built
a city in the Yucatan jungle or in the
Four Corners region of the u.s.
Southwest why having built a city there
did they then abandon the city and so my
book contains chapters on some of these
famous romantic mysteries the collapse
of Easter Island society that I'll tell
you something about the collapse of
Pitcairn Island society Pitcairn Island
famous as the uninhabited island to
which the Bounty mutineers fled but when
the Bounty mutineers landed on Pitkin in
1790 they discovered their temples and
platforms and statues of a Polynesian
settlement that had vanished why did the
first settlement of Pitkin island die
out completely leaving behind their
temples on this remote island there's
also a chapter on the quintessential
romantic mystery collapse the Maya
civilization of Guatemala and Mexico and
Honduras the most advanced Native
American society the new world before
Columbus with writing and with great art
and architecture that collapsed around
802 not 8900 leaving behind cities
covered up the jungle that a favorite
tourist destinations today there's also
a chapter on the Anasazi collapse the
one closest for Californians in the
Four Corners region the Anasazi built
the tall skyscrapers in the United
States until the skyscrapers of the
Chicago Loop with reinforced steel and
concrete in the 1870s Anasazi
skyscrapers went up to six storeys and
this in an area of desert feeding
themselves by agriculture in an area
where nobody makes a living by
agriculture today why did the Anasazi
build cities in the desert and why
having done so did they abandon them and
then if you are starting to wonder
whether collapses of civilizations are
things that before only those remote
exotic backwards people like Polynesians
and Native Americans deserve it can also
happen to Europeans and so there are the
longest section of my book is on a
society of blond-haired blue-eyed
Christian literate Europeans writing
Latin and Norse Norwegians who went out
to Greenland and 89 84 and built up a
farming society where she cows and goats
built a great stone cathedral and stone
churches and carried on for nearly 500
years longer than the longevity so far
of European settlement of North America
only to end up all dead just showing
that collapse is also something that can
befall Europeans blue-eyed blond-haired
Europeans not just problem for
Polynesians and so-called native peoples
my first plan of the book and I still
have the sketch was a book of 18
chapters on 18 collapses and I soon
realized God that's boring and
depressing to have a book of 18 chapters
on 18 collapses in addition that misses
a big point which is that it's not the
case that all past societies collapsed
there are lots of past societies that
carried on for thousands or tens of
thousands of years without any signs of
collapse and so we have an intellectual
problem to be explained why is it that
some societies solve the problems and
carried on for a long time solve the
problems that did in other societies and
so my book also contains chapters on
some
stories Iceland Japan the New Guinea
Highlanders the tikka Pia Islanders
who've maintained complex societies for
thousands or even tens of thousands of
years and finally I realized that it
wasn't enough to write a book about past
societies because today we are facing
the same problems that did in so many
past societies plus some new problems
and so half the book is also about the
difficulties facing modern societies so
there's a chapter on the American state
of Montana from which I came back two
weeks ago the state in which my wife and
kids and I spend a summer vacation each
year
Montana seemingly the most pristine and
under populated state of the lower 48
the most environmentally intact state of
the richest country in the world the
last Society you would expect to see
discussed in a book on collapse and yet
when you scratch the surface in Montana
you find a whole panoply of problems
problems of forests and fisheries and
water and soil and toxic wastes and
global warming etc the whole panoply of
problems that have dragged down
societies in the past and threaten other
societies today there's also a chapter
on the African country of Rwanda which
in 1994 solved in quotes its problems of
the environment and overpopulation in a
grisly fashion when six million Rwandan
killed nearly 1 million Rwandan and
drove another 2 million into exile the
worst case scenario of Thomas Malthus
there's a chapter on the island of
Hispaniola which is like a control
laboratory experiment in a laboratory
chemists would take two identical test
tubes and then add a dye to one and so
see the effect of the dye in history
would love to do that we don't get the
chance to do it but there are some
natural experiments approximating that
the island of Hispaniola and the
Caribbean
is divided into two countries in the
West Haiti in the east the Dominican
Republic sharing the same island and to
fly in a plane over the border from
separating Hispaniola to the Dominican
Republic is dramatic because as you fly
across the border to the west of you
it's brown and to the east of you it's
green in the Dominican Republic or if
you stand on the border you turn this
way and you see brown fields with no
trees that's Haiti and you turn this way
and you see green forests pine forest
that's the Dominican Republic Haiti
today is the saddest incipient failure
in the new world the poorest country in
the new world one of the poorest in the
world
99 percent deforested with virtually
collapsed government and on the same
island just across the border the
Dominican Republic yes the third
struggling third-world country but six
times richer than Haiti with the most
comprehensive National Park system in
the new world with about one-third of
its land still covered by Falls as close
as you can get to a controlled
experiment there's also chapter on China
the world's most populous nation whose
environmental and population problems
automatically affect more people than do
the problems of any other country just
because they are more Chinese than any
other people but also China is so big
and it's got such a huge and growing
economy that the problems of China
automatically become the problems of the
rest of the world because China is
dumping its gases and wastes into the
same atmosphere and oceans shared with
the rest of the world and finally
there's a chapter on Australia the first
world society that faces the most severe
environmental problems but that is also
today considering the most drastic
solutions to its environmental problems
as I looked at society after society I
arrived at a five-point framework for
trying to understand why some societies
succeed while other societies fail in no
particular order
one item on my five-point checklist is
human environmental impacts humans use
environmental resources in some cases we
inadvertently over exploit over harvest
our environmental resources such as our
forests and our fisheries and soils and
as a result there are societies that
have unintentionally destroyed
themselves by depleting the
environmental resources on which they
depended that's one factor of my
checklist a second factor on my
checklist to try to understand success
or failure collapse or non collapses
climate change today climate change to
us means climate change caused by humans
global warming but in the past the
climate has frequently changed for
reasons unrelated to humans in the past
the fire has sometimes gotten colder
gotten warmer gotten wetter gotten drier
and those climate changes have effects
on human societies particularly farming
societies so that a society that is
managing to deal with its environmental
problems as long as the climate is in
its favor may collapse when the climate
turns against the society for example
when it gets colder or drawing third
item on my checklist along with human
environmental impacts and climate change
is enemies most societies have neighbors
with some of which they're
intermittently at war and if a society
gets weakened for any reason including
its own environmental problems or
political or economic problems when a
society gets weakened that's the
occasion when the enemies are likely to
take advantage and walk in on the
weakened Society which means that in
continental environments it's regularly
difficult to decide whether the primary
cause of a collapse is a military defeat
or whether the primary cause was
economic environmental political
problems that weakened a society to the
point where the enemies then gave the
final blow and the classic example of
that debate is the fall of the Western
Roman Empire there's been a standing
unresolved argument we all know that
Rome the Western Roman Empire
Quotes fell you know I think ad 476 when
a Germanic chiefdom deposed the last
native Roman Emperor but the Romans had
been fighting against those barbarians
on their borders for hundreds of years
and they've been fighting them off
successfully why is that that after
centuries of victories for Rome the
barbarians filing prevailed was the real
cause of the fall of the Western Roman
Empire something about the barbarians
that they got more numerous or developed
more potent military technology or
wasn't instead that Rome got weakened by
its own environmental economic military
political problems and a weakened Rome
then received the final blow from the
barbarians in which case the fundamental
cause of the Roman collapse was Rome's
own problems the barbarians were just an
epiphenomenon the last blow that
question is still debated among
historians next last factor my check
checklist
involves relations not just with enemies
but with friends with friendly trade
partners the great majority of societies
receives some intial imports from
friendly trade partners and that means
that a society that is managing its own
environment perfectly adequately may
nevertheless collapse if a trade partner
damages its environment to the point of
collapsing so that can no longer send
the essential imports to the first
society that's a problem familiar to us
Americans at least to any of you old
enough to remember the 1973-74 Gulf oil
crisis when the United States economy
have received a severe threat not
because we were acutely messing up our
own environment but because we depended
for essential imports in this case oil
on some environmentally and politically
fragile countries and then finally the
last item on my checklist is a society's
responses whatever problems of society
faces one has to ask how a society
responds does it perceive and address
and solve the problems yes or no what
are the economic political social and
cultural facets of a society that either
allow it to meet its problems or the
cause of to fail to meet them well this
is all somewhat abstract
so let me give you a concrete example of
the collapse of the polynesian society
on easter island that built the great
stone statues how many of you here has
have been to easter island could you
raise him okay wonderful place how many
of you have seen pictures or national
Geographics or all of us have so Easter
Island its famous as the most remote
habitable scrapple land in the world an
island just fifty square miles 2,300
miles west of the coast of Chile and
1,300 miles east of the nearest
inhabited Polynesian island and a
statements for those gigantic stone
statues that sent two of you and me to
Easter Island the rest of you to see the
pictures stone statues weighing up to 80
tons and up to 33 feet high that were
carved and some have dragged and
transported up to 12 mile and then
erected into a vertical position on
platforms against the sea all this done
by people without metal tools without
graft animals without wheels without any
power other than their own muscle power
how do they do it so the collapse of
Easter Island society and how they
erected and then how they tore down
their own statues because when Europeans
arrived here comes a Tomas man like
sentence where I've lost memory of my
main verb when Europeans arrived at
least one Easter Island the Year 1720 to
this was the Dutch navigator Jakob
Roggeveen Easter I looked like the last
Island where you would expect a great
civilization erecting gigantic statues
because rogue denoted they were no trees
on the island and yet without machines
or wheels surely to erect those statues
and to drag them twelve miles the
Islanders needed wood whether to make
sleds or rollers or levers and surely
they needed also wood to make rope of
natural fiber but here's an island
without any trees no way to get wood for
transport or for rope there was no way
that they could erect the statues and in
fact the islands were in the process of
dragging nap tearing down
making the statues that their ancestors
had erected of such an enormous effort
with the resultant in 1843 the last one
hundreds of statues was torn down and
broken by the Islanders themselves a
romantic mystery why do these drylands
erect these great statues and why having
erected them did they tear them all down
and break them the answer to that
romantic mystery has emerged from
archaeological studies of the last
twenty years which other when East was
first settled by Europeans it was not
the barren treeless wasteland that we
see today but it was instead covered by
a subtropical forest that included the
world's biggest palm tree now extinct
and so the Polynesian settlers of Easter
all proceeded to chop down trees for the
same reason that we do today and that
other peoples do they chop down trees
for clearing land for agriculture and
for timber for construction and for fuel
for firewood and also to make canoes
with which to go out to the ocean to
harpoon tuna and dolphin that were their
main sources of meat and protein and
these two Islanders continued chopping
down trees until around the Year 1680
they chopped down the last tree on the
island at which point they were now out
of wood to make the sleds and the levers
and have the rope with which they
dragged and transported and erected the
giant statues so from 1680 there were no
more statues erected but without any
wood the Islanders could no longer build
canoes so they couldn't go out to sea to
harpoon to nor dolphin and that meant
that for protein for meat they turned to
the only large animal on the island
namely Homo sapiens Easter Island
Society collapsed in a civil war between
the 12 clans that whenever a clan
triumphed over another clan the
victorious clan would tear down and
break the statues of the defeated clan
and in this epidemic of cannibalism and
civil warfare from those days handed
down on Easter Island is the oral memory
of the worst insult that an Easter
Islander could shriek at another Easter
Island in those days if you wanted to
make someone else really
furious what you said to them to drive
now to the mind with rages the flesh of
your mother sticks between my teeth so
that's the end of Easter Island society
and a collapse a stark collapse the
population of Easter Island decreased by
something like 90% and the formerly
politically in cultural unified Island
collapsed in this epidemic of civil war
of all the Prius tower collapses that
I've talked about I find that the
collapse of Easter Island is the one
that grabs people most because the the
metaphor is so obvious
Easter Island isolated in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean when Easter society
collapsed there was no one else to in
the islands could turn for help
nowhere else that they could flee and
people see the metaphor if the planet if
we on earth today mess up our own planet
there is no galaxy to which we can turn
to help and no other galaxy out there to
which we can flee when I in the last
couple of years I've been teaching a
course on the material of my book to my
UCLA undergraduates they recognized the
significance of a problem that had
escaped me name how on earth did the
people do these self-destructive things
like cutting down all their trees and in
particular my UCLA students have asked
me what do you think the Islander who
chopped down the last palm tree said as
he or she was chopping down the last
palm tree my UCLA students have made a
number of suggestions for what they said
when they were cutting down the last
palm tree maybe the person who did it
said never fear technology will solve
our problems by finding a substitute for
wood
or perhaps that person chopping down the
last tree said this is my private
property this tree is mine private
property rights respect them I can do
with it whatever I please keep the big
government of the Chiefs off my back or
my UCLA students suggested maybe the
person who chopped down the last tree
said the fears of you environmentalists
are exaggerated you don't know what's
going on in some other part of the
island perhaps there are still trees out
there a ban on logging would be
premature we need more research a couple
of weeks ago few weeks ago I received an
email from someone who said I know what
the island who cut down the last tree
said as he was doing it he said never
fear
have faith God will somehow provide for
us
so that's the collapse of Easter Island
society but my book is not a depressing
book about collapses because just
collapses because it's also an account
of societies that succeeded a society
that succeeded in solving the same
problems of deforestation that did in
these dry lenders in the Mayan the
Anasazi was Japan of the Tokugawa era
Japan in the 1500s 1600s came to the end
of a civil war was unified under the so
called Tokugawa shoguns and
paradoxically the peace and prosperity
of the end of the Japanese Civil War
plunged Japan into an environmental
crisis as there was a population
explosion construction in wood the
Shogun's and the nobles building big
castles made of wood
people bid building cities of wooden
buildings which tended to burn down of
course and then rebuilding the cities in
wood and in the course of the 1600s it
became clear that the Japanese
archipelago was getting progressively
deforested and the Shogun himself was
having to employ timber from the far
northern ireland Japan Hokkaido but
fortunately the Shogun's and the
Japanese Nobles the Japanese people
recognize the problem deforestation they
solved it by combination of negative and
positive measures the negative measures
included in fact wood rationing
restricting the uses to which wood could
be put so as to reduce wood consumption
and the positive measures included
increasing wood production by developing
independently of Germany the world's
first scientific treatise the Japanese
embarked on massive tree plantations to
increase wood output and the result was
that by the time of 1853 Commodore Perry
and then the major restoration of Japan
was self-sufficient in wood and today
Japan is the first world country covered
most extensively with forests 74%
forested so there is at least as of 1853
some of you will recognize why Japan
cannot
in that respect to be considered a
success after 53 but until 1853 a
success story of managing forests in
this area which poses issues of
long-term thinking how do you manage a
society so that will last hundreds or
thousands of years they were surprised
they have been surprises to me and
perhaps the biggest set of surprises has
to do with that question that my UCLA
students have kept asking me how on
earth do people end up doing these dumb
things why do they practice such short
term thinking why don't they at least
force see a decade ahead why do people
do something so obviously dumb as to
chop down all their trees or to kill off
all their big animals or to run out of
fresh water that turns out to be an
unexpectedly complicated question there
are not simple reasons why people make
bad decisions we know that in our
individual laws we make bad decisions
sometimes sometimes we marry the wrong
person or we invest in the wrong
investment where we make a poor choice a
career and there are complicated reasons
why we make these poor choices
similarly for human groups human groups
sometimes make bad decisions for the
same reasons that individuals do but
with groups there are additional reasons
for failures of decision making problems
intrinsic in group dynamics sometimes as
the first step towards making or failing
to make a good decision it helps if you
can anticipate a problem before it
arrives but a first reason for cause for
failure is a society that or an
individual that fails to anticipate the
problem before the problem appears and
so misses a chance to abort the problem
as society may fail to anticipate a
problem because it reasons by false
analogy or because there's been no
precedent for the problem in the
societies experience example global
warming today why on earth did we not
thirty years ago recognized that global
warming was coming on
why didn't we anticipate the problem of
global warming it's simple they had
never in human history been so many
people putting out so many much
greenhouse gas as to be able to heat up
the temperature of the whole globe it
was unprecedented unimaginable instead
until 30 years ago people were concerned
about global cooling rather than global
warming so we did not anticipate the
problem of global warming
Assaf that we were stupid it was on an
anticipated unprecedented a second
reason why societies may fail to solve
problems is that even after they failed
to anticipate in problem arise people
may fail to perceive a problem that is
there around them some problems
developing literally an imperceptible
fashion developed slowly another example
is again global warming why is it that
it took us now 30 years to recognize the
reality of global warming why didn't we
see after 7 years that the world was
starting to cook and the reason is is
simple of it's that global warming began
literally imperceptibly it was not the
case that in 1970 world average
temperature was this in 1971 a degree
warmer 1972 two degrees warmer one
degree warmer every year if that had
been the case then after seven years the
world would been seven degrees warmer
would been clearer but know you know
that climate doesn't have that way
climate fluctuates there's a warmer year
and then a cold year and then a couple
of cold years and then another warming
cup of warm summer's then some cold year
warm cold climate fluctuates and it took
30 years before every knowledgeable
scientists and climatologist concerned
with these issues of climate was abled
were able to agree that behind this
noisy fluctuating signal there really
was a long-term trend of global warming
that's why we didn't see it after seven
years the beginning of global warming
were literally imperceptible and that's
also why it took 30 years before the
heads of state of every government on
earth except for the head of state of
Australia and one other country have
recognized the importance of global
warming a third reason why society may
fail to solve a problem if it hasn't
anticipated it or hasn't perceived it is
that the society may even not try to
solve a problem that it recognizes and
that's especially puzzling how on earth
would a society or an individual not try
to solve a problem that you recognize
but there are lots of reasons including
conflicts of interest in many cases to
perpetuate the problem is in the
interests of some individuals or some
group within the society and if that
group gets big certain benefits and if
everybody else suffers disadvantages but
those disadvantages a more diffuse and
less certain then there's a strong lobby
to perpetuate the problem that again is
the case with global warming
perpetuating global warming by
continuing to burn greenhouse gases is
in the interest of some elements of our
society for example some autumn
automobile manufacturers and oil
companies but it's not the case that all
oil companies are neglect the importance
so the issue of global warming a couple
of them unfortunately continue to do so
and a couple are well attuned to the
issue so conflicts of interest sometimes
result in people not addressing problems
that are going to do them in there are
obviously some lessons of history
lessons of these past collapses relevant
to our present situation today the most
transparent lesson is to take
environmental problems seriously there
are lots of past societies with only
10,000 people the Easter Islanders
equipped with just stone tools of wooden
stew wooden tools and yet those past
societies managed to eventually to
destroy their environments and to do
themselves in if past societies with a
few people and the relatively weak
technology were capable of destroying
themselves you better believe that we
are doing it
a much more rapidly that's a transparent
conclusion but there were also some
deeper conclusions of that emerge for me
only in the last stages of working on my
book and in fact they've been growing on
me since then these really are problems
of long-term thinking what are the
long-term long-term features of a
society that distinguish in the long run
the successes and the failures and here
I recognize I think two groups of
factors relevant to long now thinking
one has to do with the role of the elite
in a society societies in which the
elite are capable of insulating
themselves from the consequences of
their actions
those are societies that are more likely
to do themselves in by failing to solve
their problems because the elite
insulated from the consequences of their
actions are cut off from the problems
that they are creating the lack of
motivation to solve example the Maya
Maya civilization of the Yucatan
Guatemala Mexico Honduras collapsed in
the eight hundreds of nine why as a
result especially deforestation soil
erosion why on earth did the Maya Kings
not just look out the windows of the
palaces and see the forest gone from the
hillsides and the soil rolling down from
the hillsides covering up the buildings
down in the valley bottoms up to a depth
of quite a few feet why did the Maya
King see it I'm sure they saw it but
they were insulated from the
consequences of deforestation soil
erosion because the Maya Kings were
living basically by taxing the commoners
Maya Kings were living luxuriously at
the expense of the commoners they did
not suffer the consequences of
deforestation and soil erosion until it
was too late
even as the commoners were beginning to
get malnourished and starved until it
was too late
and the commoners rose and revolt and
overthrew the Kings and burnt the
palaces of the Kings the Maya Kings had
insulated themselves from the
consequences of their actions and the
result were not motivated to solve their
problems whereas there are other
societies takagawa Japan the Shogun
suffer the consequences of deforestation
just as did everybody else in Japan and
so the Shogun was motivated to solve
Japan's forestry problems I must say
that one of the things that concerns me
increasingly today in the United States
is this phenomenon of insulation of the
elite which has been growing
conspicuously within the last decade the
degree to which a lead Americans wealthy
Americans Americans in a position of
political power are doing things to
ensure that they are walled off from the
consequences of their actions and so are
not motivated to solve the broader
problems of society the Enron phenomenon
in Southern California it takes the
phenomenon takes the form of the so
called gated community that's been
proliferating in Southern California in
the last decade that I be living there
in the gated community of affluent
people live explicitly behind gates
isolated from society's broader problems
and so they're not motivated to solve
problems municipal water supplied
because they drink bottled water they're
not motivated to solve the problems the
police force public police force because
they've got private security guards
they're not motivated to solve the
problems of the public schools because
the kids go to private schools they're
not motivated to solve the issues of
social security because they will retire
on private pensions and they were also
not motivated to solve the problems of
national medical insurance or the lack
thereof again because they did they
depend upon private health insurance and
this phenomenon in the United States is
growing the installation of powerful
Americans the decision makers from the
rest of society in the past that's been
a blueprint for trouble it's also a
phenomenon not only within the United
States but also between first world
countries and the rest of the world the
first world is increasingly behaving
like a gated community towards the rest
of the world that's to say adopting the
attitude that we in the first world can
continue to consume even though we see
the messes that are being caused out
there in the third world even though we
see the increasing number of third world
countries that are suffering from
problems of resource shortage and
overpopulation and at least for a while
we in the first world can get away with
insulating ourselves from the world's
problems just as the Maya Kings for a
while
insulated themselves from the world's
problems but September 11th 2001 was or
should have been a wake-up call to
Americans that in the long run long now
thinking the United States and Japan and
Australia and Europe the first world is
not no longer going to be able to
insulate it cells from the problems of
the third world so that's one of the
deep lessons and I think the other deep
lesson that I was realizing only towards
the end of my work and that has been
growing on me in the time since I
finished my book has to do with the
question of core values again why do
some societies succeed in solving their
problems and others while others are
failing
part of the reason has to do with a
willingness to reappraise core values
every society has its core values that
it holds dear in the United States
devout values of freedom and of
aspiration opportunities for everybody
but every society has its core values
and yet conditions change and when
conditions change the core values that
may have served the society well in the
past may no longer be serving the
society well at our present and so a
society faces the issue of whether to
change core values it's agonizing to
jettison the values that have served you
well in the past it may be essential to
carrying on a society that does not is
unwilling to change its core values when
conditions change may destroy itself by
behaving inappropriately
the Green Lenore's for example maintain
their society for 450 years remote from
Europe by their core value of their
identity as European Christians and that
enable them to survive as the most
remote outpost of Europe from 89 84
until 1450 and that was fine until sea
ice began to cut off trade with Norway
and until the inward the Eskimos arrived
in Greenland
the Norwegians in Greenland were racist
Christians who despise the Inuit and as
long as climate and the environment was
in their favor they could get away with
it but when the climate turned against
them the fact was that these pagan Inuit
had a much more successful subsistence
economy than to the Norse
the Norse clung to their identity as
Christians refused to learn from the
unit and a result ended up all dead by
clinging to the values the core values
that had given them success for 450
years that again is an issue today there
are societies today that have been
willing to reappraise their core values
I was living in Europe in the late 50s
and early 60s when Europeans were
undergoing an agonizing appraisal
reappraising their core value of the
nation-state Europeans had regarded
themselves for centuries as citizens of
the nation-state and it had been the
basis for Europe's prosperity but also
in the 20th century it had become the
basis for too awful world wars then
after the Second World War Europeans
began saying our identity as
nationalistic citizens of Germany or
France served us well in the past and it
ruined us in the 20th century and we
can't afford another such war so we have
to change our core values and start
considering ourselves Europeans and
there was that the agonizing reappraisal
that I saw going on particularly in
Britain in the late 1950s and is still
going on today in in Europe with the the
turndown of the EU Constitution in in
France and the Netherlands but that's
not the last word the fact is that
Europeans have been able to
substantially reappraise their core
values and as a result have been making
a transition that promises Europe power
and economic strength who would not have
had otherwise again this is something
that concerns me in the United States
today the Maricruz had held two core
values that in the past since seventeen
a 1776 have been the source of our
identity and strength and served us well
in the past but are no longer serving us
well the two prime core values that are
up for reappraisal in the United States
today with which we are struggling or
our traditional value of isolationism
and consumerism for a long time the
United States was isolationist George
Washington's farewell address taught us
to stay clear of entangling alliances to
be isolationist and was good advice that
George Washington gave us as long as the
Atlantic Pacific oceans in fact could
shield us from any country strong enough
to be a threat to us after the first
world war when we did in to get involved
in Europe we pulled back into our
traditional isolationism we could get
away with it but nowadays particularly
since September 11 2001 it's clear that
isolation doesn't work it doesn't solve
long-term problems it can solve
short-term problems because there are
too many countries waiting to blow up
and so Americans are starting to go
through the painful reappraisal of
getting involved in the long term long
now thinking getting involved in the
long term with countries overseas the
opposite of our strengths of isolation
and throughout our history the other
American value that is up for
reappraisal now is a value of
consumerism the fact is that the United
States is the richest country in the
world we've consumed more than any other
country and our ideal of consumerism
made sense as long as there were few
relatively few Americans in a rich
environment and today our consumerism
that made us the richest country in the
world no longer makes sense because the
world is running out of resources and
the world including the United States is
increasing in number of people so we are
starting to reappraise our consumerism
that was the source of our strength in
the past and will ruin us in the future
if we cling to it but it's going to be a
painful reappraisal as any of you who
watches Super Bowl halftime ads knows
well one finally one might one might
object well
to draw lessons from the past for the
present that's not fear because there
are big differences from the past and
present
you can't just extrapolate directly from
the past to the present yes that's true
there are differences between the past
and present and you have to take account
of those differences if you want to be
able to learn from the past if you want
to be able to draw lessons from history
you have to recognize differences
between the past and present some of
those differences make our present
situation worse more dangerous for
example I mentioned that in the past
societies consist of relatively few
people with weak technology but today
there are six and a half billion of us
with metal tools and bulldozers and
nuclear power not ten thousand Easter
Islanders with stone tools we are
hammering away at our environment with
much more power and much faster than any
past Society that makes our present
situation more dangerous than the
situation of past societies another
difference between the past and present
is that in the past societies could
collapse one by one when Easter Island
collapsed Easter Island society collapse
nobody else in the world knew about it
nobody was affected by it and similarly
when the Maya collapsed it had some
reverberations maybe in the valley of
Mexico but certainly none in the
southeastern United States or in the
Andes and none at all in Europe nobody
knew about
nobody was affected by the Maya collapse
but today thanks to globalization every
society potentially can affect any other
society and that means that the risk we
have faced today is not the risk of an
isolated collapse that's now impossible
but of a global collapse one knows that
from recent history if twenty years ago
you would ask some Congress person with
no interest in the environment and
concern only with global security issues
to name the countries in the world of
most complete irrelevance to the
geopolitical interests of the United
States because they were so remote and
so poor people in fact went through this
exercise and on the 1986 list of the
country's most relevant to America
interests were of course Somalia and
Afghanistan and except for its oil Iraq
but because of globalization all three
of those countries have seen
interventions of American troops the
American government has seen fit send
troops to these remote poor countries
Somalia Afghanistan and Iraq because of
globalization what happens anywhere even
in country like Somalia affects the
interests of the first world today there
are waves of immigration emigration that
are unstoppable
and the first world grows resources from
the rest of the world the first world
attracts terrorists and emergent
diseases from the rest of the world so
the risk that we face today is not of
Easter Island like collapse in isolation
but of a global collapse those two thing
could make one pessimistic but people
often ask me Jared after all this are
you a pessimist or an optimist and maybe
after what I've told you you say well he
must be a pessimist but the fact is that
despite all this I'm a cautious optimist
and reason that I'm cautious optimist so
I think that things could turn out okay
is the great advantage that we enjoy
over all past societies namely we are
the only Society in world history that
is capable of learning from the
difficulties being faced by societies
remote from us in space so in the
morning you turn on your TV sets and you
see what's happening today in Iraq or
Rwanda or Nepal you can learn from these
remote countries but when the Easter
Islanders were chopping down their last
tree in 1680 Easter Islanders didn't
have TV sets and they had no way of
knowing that Japan in 1680 was in the
process of solving its forestry problems
while Haiti in the 1680s was getting
launched on creating forestry problems
so we have that unique advantage and the
related unique advantage we have is that
we have the first society in world
history with a capable capability of
learning from the past because we've got
archaeologists and historians to tell us
about the successes of the ticka pians
and the beginni Highlanders and the
failures of the Maya and the Anasazi and
Easter Islanders the pict
at islanders again when the Easter
Islanders chop which are getting ready
to chop down that last tree in 1680
these dry lenders didn't have
archeologists or historians to tell them
that 800 years previously Maya
civilization collapsed for the exact
same reason that Easter Island Society
was now on the verge of collapsing or
that the Anasazi had collapsed just 500
years earlier so we are we have this
great advantage we're the first society
in world history with a potential for
learning from society's remote from us
in space and remote from us in time and
my hope for the sake of the generation
of my 18 year old twin sons and our
children my hope is that we will choose
to make use of that advant and learn
from the past and become one of the
success stories rather than one of the
failures
[Applause]
quite a swarm of questions here by the
way if you're not asking a question and
somebody near you looks like they want
one of these blank cards go ahead and
hand it if you want one of these blank
cards go ahead and beg around the people
around you to see if you get something
and if that doesn't work tear a leaf out
of the back of this book or something
I'll start with your book this is a
question from Tom it's going to be the
one what do people most often
misunderstand about your work first off
right over here what do people most
often misunderstand about my work my
sense has been that the people who
misunderstand my work of all those who
went into it with a preconceived view
and were not receptive to seeing what's
happened in history there have been a
couple of critical reviews by well-known
people whose views are well known it was
to be expected that Greg Easterbrook
would write a negative review in The New
York Times in fact I was pleasantly
surprised that he voted one quarters
review saying what a good book this was
before he then said that it was wrong
because this is this is a person who has
made a career out of disparaging reports
of environmental problems um this is
actually question for me
you wrote you finish the book as I
recall almost a year ago now oh they get
them to print faster now that's kind of
interesting in its own right that you
must have seen and noticed some things
both in the world and your students and
in the course of making this television
series that you would have put in the
book if you know a year ago could you
run by any of those things sure there
are things that I would put in the book
now if I were if I were finishing off
the book now I came back a month ago
from Australia where I was doing the
publicity tour for the release of the
Australian edition of the book and
Australia at the time that I was there I
was and still is in the most serious
drought in Australian history I'm a
major Australian city with a population
more than 100,000 was within a few
months of having to bring water in by
truck and Sydney Australia's bigger city
with a population four and a half
million has its reservoirs a 38%
capacity and dropping dropping but
Sydney doesn't have any walk any aquifer
beneath it and it doesn't have
desalinization plants is going to be
quite spectacular if a city of four and
a half million at the rate that Sydney
is going now
it's estimated that Sydney has between
one year and 20 months to solve its
water problems that's going to be
spectacular facility of four and a half
million fails to solve its water problem
I would put that in my book and are you
an optimist on that one I'm a cautious
optimist and that was
Australians take their environmental
problems more seriously than we do or
Japanese for the simple reason that
they've got the most fragile environment
and they know it
there's going to be a pair of related
questions they're kind of long but
they're worthy and long ones from above
copic and the other from Sam Borka sinto
are you guys on there one over here
Bob copic asks don't democracies have a
disadvantage of a necessary resource for
example force may be destroyed for jobs
and profit if the resource is saved once
won't the issue arise again later over
and over but one wrong decision will do
in the resource in the society same
Bergesen puts a little more generically
do you see any connections between types
of government and response to serious
societal problems for example in other
words is it possible that our own system
is poorly equipped to deal with our own
long-term problems that's a very
interesting question it's a good
question the general question about
whether democracies or dictatorships are
centrally guided societies are better
equipped to solve these difficult
environmental problems one can make
April a priori arguments such as the one
outlined in your question there a priori
reasons why you might expect democracies
to be less successful law successful
dictatorships etc surveying democracies
and dictatorships I do not see an
average difference that's to say they
are democracies that have made messes
and there were democracies that have
courageously solved their problems there
are dictatorships that made messes and
dictatorships that have solved their
problems among dictatorships for example
Tokugawa Japan was a dictatorship
Indonesia is the dictatorship and at
least for some time the Sahara area era
Indonesia had a minister of the
environment Emile Salim who had the ear
of President Suharto and who in this
country without an indigenous grassroots
movement instituted a large-scale
national park system so dictatorships
can do some good things they can also do
some grateful things
Duvalier the dictator of Haiti
did some made some dreadful
contributions towards deforestation and
again in democracies of the United
States to mark American democracy just a
minute now that the guy who ran sander
Domingo which is your wonderful example
against Haiti was not exactly a glowing
Democrat no no to his oh well Trujillo
the guy who runs ran the Dominican
Republic was is usually considered the
newest most evil dictator in history the
new world and yet so and he did lots of
absolutely awful things paradoxically
his environmental policies worked out
that are much better for the dr than did
Duvalier's for haiti for the selfish
reason that Trujillo wanted to enrich
themselves by meant by maintaining the
pine forest as property for himself and
so he prevented all the people from
chopping down the Pauly Flores there's
an example of a totally despicable
person doing something that doing at
least one thing that had some beneficial
side effects and among democracies the
United States leave some things to be
desired in a democracies environmental
policies today but there are other
democracies notably Sweden the
Netherlands Norway Iceland especially
Iceland and Australia that are doing
some rather bold natural things for the
environment so long-winded way of saying
on the average I would say that
dictatorships lurch more from very bad
to very good then do democracies but on
the average they are dumb and bright
dictators just as they're dumb and
bright presidents
related of other countries and you know
you're always going to look at bio
geographical situations and Japan is an
island Iceland is an island now
Greenland was also an island but a
peculiar in a sense of colonized Island
whereas it feels me like Iceland was
more its own complete thing and they're
doing their own personal genome of the
entire place and taking a very seriously
green approach to things is that partly
because they're an island as well as a
very old democracy I think there are
differences that's an interesting point
about Japan and Iceland because yes the
islands but also they represent opposite
extremes of islands Iceland is
environmentally one of the most fragile
islands Iceland ended up virtually
totally deforested and lost half of its
topsoil but in that case the Icelanders
learn their lesson and they now have a
whole government Department devoted to
reforesting Iceland and at the opposite
extreme of Japan Japan's success in
reforesting itself is partly because of
policy but also that Japan had an easier
job Japan is the first world country
with the highest rainfall most fertile
soils so trees grow rapidly we grow
rapidly in Japan the Japanese had an
easier problem as well as successful
politics it occurs to me that both Japan
and Iceland also have frames of
reference of long-term thinking and
Iceland a great deal of knowledge about
their own history and concerned with it
part of their genetic interest is in
their own genealogy and in Japan you
have the traditions of Shinto expressed
in the say shrine and other of these
things which really reach over centuries
quite comfortably and you know a
question here is does great regard for
ancestors play into this at all that's a
that's a very good point and I think it
ties in in the following additional way
that if you're on an island that has
been self-contained for long time as has
Iceland and Japan you get used to the
fact that you are going to have to
manage with your own resources and
that's not the case in a society with
borders where if you make a mess you at
least have the strategy of going and
grabbing those resources from the people
next to so I think it's no accident that
Japan at least for some time and Iceland
today as we're taught at managing this
environment of being self-contained
keeps the consequence is close to well
yeah
here's a question from mark Lavoie
professor at Stanford are you waving
back there most of the societies look
this a little bit but there's a clinker
at the end of it most of the societies
whose collapse you described or isolated
at some level how much does Thomas
Friedman's flat world prevent Jared
Diamond's collapse in the long run
parentheses unless the entire planet
collapses yeah it's true that the lost
rivet examples that I discussed in my
book are drawn disproportionately but
not solely from isolated societies
because you know and that's for a lot of
reasons and isolated societies things
tend to happen faster and they're
cleaner and there are fewer confounding
influences of neighbors but also in my
book this whole chapter on the lawyer
who are the most advanced society the
new world in the most populous embedded
part of a new world before Columbus
Mesoamerica and there are other
continental embedded societies that have
collapsed which I did not discuss again
for a luster of Reason if I had done the
eighteen chapters of 18 collapses you
would have had a chapter on the Harappan
collapse of the Indus Valley
Civilisation and there would have been a
chapter on the chimera collapse of
what's now Cambodia and there would have
been a chapter on Great Zimbabwe in
Africa and there would have been a
chapter on Cahokia outside st. Louis and
there would have been a chapter on the
Fertile Crescent Iraq Iran etc so the
isolated society is a moral us truth but
it's not the case that the societies
with neighbors are immune from problems
what do you think about planetary
collapse
planetary the risk that we face today
the new risk that we face today is the
risk of a planetary of collapse
namely the problems my worst case
scenario my the gentle version my worst
case in rem is not not a nuclear
holocaust or an epidemic but the
conditions of Somalia and Rwanda just
gradually spread and conditions of Nepal
gradually spread more and Haiti
gradually spread more and more countries
collapsed and gets and the United States
which is now intervening with 150,000
troops and two and fifty billion dollars
in one country there are 25 billion
countries out there that the United
States has intervene in and that's my
gentle decline scenario that's a glide
path the Oblivion scenario so in the
interview is globalization part of the
current planetary robustness or part of
its brittleness both ways look
globalization can buffer if you run out
of resources you can get them from
somewheres else Japan today is
maintaining its forest cover how by
globalization by pillaging the forests
of all the countries are forests yeah
but globalization can buffer you but
globalization also exposes you as those
American troops have went into Somalia
and Iraq now here's a question from
Brendan O'Connor who says I'm 22 close
to 20 where are you way back thank you
all of your examples of societal
collapse have environmental destruction
as some sort of cause what is the
situation I guess are there examples of
purely social or political collapse
absolutely yes that there are examples
of purely political social or military
collapse while environmental factors
have played a role I think in the
majority of the well-known collapses of
past societies there are cases of
collapses without an environmental
component just to the collapse of
Carthage in 146 BC was purely military
conquest by the Romans and the virtual
collapse of Paraguay in the 1800s the
depopulation and political collapse of
Paraguay was not because of Paraguay's
environmental problems but because
Paraguay made the mistake of fighting a
war
while simultaneously against Bolivia and
Argentina and Uruguay don't forget
Uruguay and that was a big mistake
militarily and imp resulted in the
collapse of Paraguay so yes there are
collapses oh and the collapse of the
Soviet Union a recent example yes the
Soviet Union made awful environmental
messes but it appears that the
nevertheless it was not those
environmental messes that did in the
Soviet Union 15 years ago but it was the
Soviet Union's especially economic and
resulting political military problems so
the answer is yes there are collapses
without a big environmental component
okay here's a bobcat back again wave
your hand again how do you think the New
Guinea people will fare a few hundred
years after oil runs out and the big
die-off occurs isn't there a good chance
they will be in better shape than our
descendants yes of course the New
Guineans will be have a good chance of
being in better shape of our than our
descendants because New Guineans have
been self-sufficient and cut off from
the outside world until very recently a
one of my New Guinea friends was on the
expedition it was on the party that made
the last stone axes in his area in the
1970s and Peter still knows how to make
stone axes of the New Guinea villages in
that I visited last August were still
self-sufficient growing all their own
food with minimal dependence on anything
from the outside world so yes if there
is a global collapse New Guineans will
be very well positioned to carry on
while we Americans who don't know how to
light a fire or how to get food except
from a supermarket card will have some
difficulties
this is question from Rajeev a time
value of money drives most
decision-making is this one of the prime
causes of short-term thinking what was
the first word of that time value of
money district took time time value of
money does this drive most this is one
of the prime causes of short-term
thinking it's a I don't know that it's a
product there are so many there are so
many causes of short-term thinking but
but yes that is a cause of short-term
thinking particularly among professional
economists who think in terms of what's
called discounting that's to say a
thousand dollars ten years in the future
is not as valuable as a thousand dollars
today because you can earn interest in
next ten years
and economists broaden that argument to
say that it makes sense it's perfectly
okay to chop down the forest some to to
drive into extinction the fisheries
today if the money that we earn by
deforesting and overfishing gets
invested in other stuff such as human
capital this is a common fallacy on the
part of economists and reminds me of a
book by an economist on whose title page
appeared if I can get it right the
following quote in a world of finite
resources the only people who believe in
the possibility of unlimited growth are
idiots and economists
do you identify other nail ball causes
of short-term thinking lots of causes of
short-term thinking other causes of
short-term thinking they include
desperation for example why is it in the
tropical third world that fishermen
dynamite the reefs in order to get fish
even though these fishermen know very
well the value of the reefs and they
know that they're destroying their own
livelihood and the potential livelihood
for their children because of short-term
desperation of getting the food for
their children tomorrow
or why is it that some New Guinea groups
sell leases to logging companies
DeForest their land even though they
know better than anybody else the
products that they get for free from
their forest again
short-term desperation of needing the
cash to buy clothes and food and
schoolbooks for their children those are
some of the motives behind short-term
thinking this may be a core values
question as well because it occurs to me
when Ryan and I were on Easter Island we
talked to the same archaeologist you did
I think and he told the story of a
lobster fishery just was discovered
around the Easter Island little
archipelago there some years ago it was
great because they could you know eat
the lobsters but sell them to Chile so
they call them all and sold them all to
Chile and now they're in any lobsters
left and we sort of asked you know come
on these guys must know better than
anybody not to make that kind of mistake
and his answer was he thought it was in
some sense of Polynesian core value I
see I seem to be more general than that
what why is the fisherman Jennifer why
is it that the great majority of the
world's fisheries are overfished why is
it that lobster fishermen throughout the
world larger sinistra but lobster
fishermen on see now around Australia of
over fish why is that the European Union
the fishermen in the world were the most
detailed scientific information about
the consequences overfishing why is the
e why is the EU having over fish their
own waters now all the fish in the
waters in Africa and other countries I
don't see anything uniquely pol yeah
there may be something about the way we
think about the ocean that it seems like
an infinity that you can tap or
something here's a leading question from
reporter Mark Hertz guard the Nation
magazine do you agree with Stuart brand
that climate change is so threatening to
our future that we must turn to nuclear
power for much of our future energy
supply good luck with that I was not
aware that Stuart brand had said this
but if I had known that he would have
said this I would say said said yes to
deal with our energy problems we need
everything that is available to us
including nuclear France today generates
I believe 80% of its power from nuclear
sources and has done it very carefully
and has never had a nuclear accident
Britain now is going through one of its
agonizing reappraisal to the core values
about whether to bring back nuclear
power of the United States had bad
experiences but the fact is that we get
some percentage of our power today from
nuclear and our nuclear plants were all
old and again get phased out so what are
we going to do when the nuclear plants
get phased out but what are we also
going to do when we deplete fossil fuels
a few months ago you probably know the
the report of the bipartisan Commission
the National Energy Commission that
released a thoroughly practical this is
not pie in the sky environmental a
thoroughly practical energy policy to
the United States where are we going to
get our energy from and they went
through all the possibilities some of it
can come from nuclear if done carefully
like France and some of it can come from
wind there are some really SuperDuper
new windmills and some of it can come
from tidal and some of it can come from
solar and some of it can come from
better use of coal data together so yes
I grew was agree with Stuart brand on
that as well as I think all a lot of
matters I
I did not expect that answer Marc deal
with it okay here's a question from Mike
cluck where's Mike buck waiting back
there and this would be the last
question is it you'll see why are there
plans to make collapse into a
documentary to eat reach a broader
audience interesting question some of
you may know that Guns Germs steal my
previous book has been made into a
documentary which is now showing in fact
the first episode I'm aired on PBS
this past Monday and if you like that
first episode the next two episodes are
even better on this coming Monday you'll
see on PBS 10:00 to 10:00 p.m. or 9 p.m.
check your local listings you'll see on
PBS of the confrontation between Europe
and the new world and particularly
creation of the battle calf lock the
National Geographic Alliance TV got
1,000 Quechua Indians including great
guy to play out of walpa and magnify
them by computer to 80,000 to restage
the battle calf marker so that's next
Monday and the following week Monday the
the what is that Monday the 25th will be
the future a program on Africa which you
find a gut-wrenching program so I and
those involved in the Guns Germs and
Steel television program have been
waiting to see how the ggs television
program would fare with the public
before getting concrete about the
possibility of a TV series on collapse I
hope there will be a TV series on
collapse and I would add that any of you
here with about three million dollars to
spare who would like to do who would
like to get an environmental message to
tens of millions hundreds of millions
people around the world lots more people
watch TV program programs than read
Jared Diamond's book and the ggs program
cost four and a half million of which
one and a half million was generated
internally so it cost about 3 million of
grands if any of you would like to put
up three million
then you can short-circuit what
otherwise will be an agonizing search
for money and you can launch a TV series
of collapse right away and that is a
wonderful note on which drift thank you
and good night
you